hi I'm laurdiy I'm a YouTuber podcast
host and TV host and this is the wired
autocomplete interview
shocking the amount of times that I've
died online
[Music]
what is Lord DIY real name my real name
is Lauren Kobayashi riyamaki it's a lot
of syllables I got really lucky and when
a lot of YouTubers were naming their
channels like mac lover baby Barbie
twinkle glitter 45. I stuck to something
a little more straightforward so Laura
obviously the first half of my name and
then DIY which was like the trajectory
of uh my content and so I got really
lucky because I got to keep my name when
a lot of people had to Rebrand when they
decided that they didn't want to be
Beauty lover glitter 45 twinkle
starcloud what was Laura diy's first
viral video I got really lucky and it
was like my second or third-ish video
and it did really well on Tumblr thrived
on Tumblr it was like a skull back
t-shirt so like the the back of the
shirt was like very edgy and tumbler and
like alternative what show was Lord DIY
on I host an executive produce craftopia
craftopia is a DIY craft challenge show
it's three contestants two challenges
One winner that sounded very hosty right
there like three contestants two
challenges One winner what
camera does Lord DIY use the iPhone
camera is shockingly good now on
cinematic mode specifically oh my God oh
my God it's so good and then I Vlog on a
Canon
a Canon
EOS M50 if log in a Canon M50 with a
wide angle lens and then um for main
Channel videos I shoot on a 5D so
dramatic
okay how many subscribers this Lord DIY
I have just under 8.5 million
subscribers Blood Sweat and Tears for
the last 10 years is how we came to be
at 8.5 million subscribers but I mean
it's been 10 years and I've been pretty
consistently uploading like a video a
week for 10 years with like a mental
breakdown scheduled on like a quarterly
basis so there's been a few breaks but
for the most part it's been 10 years of
making consistent videos how many
tattoos does Lord DIY have Mom this is a
great time to skip ahead in the video I
think I have 14 now I've got a 73 Vega
here my dad has one and it's been like a
family thing that's been in our family
forever I got my Japanese beta name here
and then this is a cootie catcher
there's absolutely no meaning behind it
I just thought it was cute how old is
Lord DIY dog my dog moose is just over
five years old so I brought moose home
at eight weeks and so it's really
interesting because his life is is
basically documented from like the
moment he came home at eight weeks up
until now so like every birthday that
moose has had there's probably a vlog I
was just watching his first bath video
adorable but like I'm so glad that I
have those moments you know kind of like
Frozen in time in the form of a vlog
because he just grows up so fast how to
tie-dye Lord DIY so I've done a handful
of tie-dye videos I had a lord DIY
tie-dye kit tie-dye really had its
moment so I feel like I've done like a
few different tutorials like how to do
tie-dye using crushed ice on top of
shirts and different ways to tie it so
there's definitely a ton of existing
tie-dye content that I've made over the
last couple years oh my God this feels
so like why is Laura DIY leaving YouTube
oh my God mental breakdowns mental
breakdowns on mental breakdowns on
mental breakdowns I think because people
are so involved and this is like the
beauty of YouTube is like being engaged
with your audience is that you kind of
have to give your audience I mean you
don't always have to I've just been the
type of YouTuber who gives my audience a
heads up when I need to take a break I
think it's also you know just nice to
share your experience with like needing
to be like hey I'm really stressed out I
need to like go lay somewhere for a
really long time and like not do
anything and so I've always been really
open but when I take a break and so I
think you know in the past having made
videos that might feel a little dramatic
in the moment when I'm having the mental
breakdown they think that like I'm
leaving forever but I probably am not
leaving forever anytime soon coming back
can be kind of stressful because you're
like oh my God I have to come back with
a banger like an absolute Banger it
could be really stressful but for the
most part people are just like excited
that you're making content again so I
used to like put a lot of pressure on
myself to make like a crazy good video
video coming back but now I'm just like
hey here's my dog and I getting lunch
today and it's way less pressure when
did Laura DIY start her podcast on my
birthday August 11th
2012 years ago two years ago and a
little bit wow the math thing was
struggling so we taught our two year
anniversary and just passed our 100th
episode Mark and it's been an amazing
experience so far laurdiy merch is this
like is this supposed where I'm supposed
to like plug my merch right here like
this is kind of great I just make things
that I think are cute and a lot of the
times my audience also happens like
they're cute and it's a great way to
just you know like make something cute
that other people can share with you for
me I don't really it's like not a big
money making business it's more just
that like like for example I have a new
trucker hat because I love trucker hats
and so like I made a trucker hat that
like I was excited to wear and luckily
other people also wanted to wear it
where does Laura DIY get her plushies
someone actually just introduced me to
this app and this is next level crazy
like I almost don't want to put this on
the internet okay so squishmallows I
feel like are having their moment right
now like it was tie-dye a year and a
half ago but it's squishmallows now and
like as a millennial I just feel like
you can be a successful multi-million
business owner but also go home and lay
on a squishable on the couch and like we
shouldn't get shamed for that so anyway
there's this app called squish alert
which literally tells you on what
websites like rare squishmallows go in
stock because people are psychotic with
squishmallows and it is nearly
impossible to get one in like regular
stores I may be exposing and people are
going to be mad who have been like
gatekeeping squish alert but sorry about
it where was Lord DIY born I was born in
St Catharines Ontario Canada it's a like
Suburban medium medium maybe a
medium-ish city just outside of Niagara
Falls okay where is Lord DIY why parents
from St Catharines Ontario Canada born
and raised baby
thank you so much what awards does Lord
DIY have so the Streamys is kind of like
the Oscars for YouTubers where we like
all leave our house for the first time
in a really long time because like we're
all you know homebodies it wasn't like a
life-changing event in terms of Channel
growth but it was like a really great
piece for my Visa application to be able
to still work in the states like the
immigration office really loved the
streamy awards so thank you Streamys for
letting me continue to be in the United
States okay what is Lord diy's Poshmark
I don't think poshmark's URLs work the
same where it's like poshmark.com
whatever but I do put some of my my old
stuff on Poshmark gently used sometimes
never used at all because they have a
shopping problem Lord DIY officials my
username on Poshmark what college did
laurdiy go to I went to a university in
downtown Toronto called Ryerson
University but Mr egerton Ryerson was
not the greatest guy so they actually
just to change the name of the
university to the I think it's like
Toronto Metropolitan University or
something so Ryerson University does not
exist anymore which is really fun for my
degree that's hanging on the wall in my
parents house what
print Lord DIY are you so 17 magazine on
their website did a what percent Lord
DIY are you quiz at some point and I
think that I got like 75 or 90 I was
like [ __ ] what question do I answer
wrong of my own life that I'm not 100
Lord DIY I was like slightly offended
but I was like okay maybe like I've
changed some personal growth and I'm not
as lore DIY as I used to be or like is
it evolution of Lord DIY 2.0 like I you
know it was I it kind of set me smiling
into like a self-reflection moment
thanks so much for having me wired um
you can find me on the internet at
laurdiy